le dernier tgv qui s'arrête en gare de
lons le saunier ne sera bientôt plus
qu'un souvenir
la ligne marseille strasbourg sera
supprimée début 2019 la plupart des
usagers déplorent cette annonce parce
que très embêtant parce que du coup je
sais que je trouve ce soit des blablas
car ce sont des choses comme ça parce
que l'on sait quand même vachement
pratique prendre j'habite à oyonnax donc
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué ça
s'arrête pas aux lyonnais a donc choisi
de venir à lens déjà alors la cia pod ci
a pu tgv je sais pas comment on va faire
la raison de cette suppression des
travaux à lyon part-dieu desservie par
cette ligne
cette gare est prévu pour quarante mille
passagers par jour mais elle en
accueille 120 milles
le chantier d'agrandissement devrait
durer quatre ans la ville et la région
veulent qu au contraire la mise en place
de davantage de liaisons vers lyon dans
un communiqué elle déclare refuser la
suppression unilatérale et sans
contrepartie de la desserte tgv
strasbourg-marseille une pétition a
également été mise en ligne par un
adjoint au maire et président d'une
association de défense des intérêts de
la ville et un département le plus
industriel en france on a des pépites
sur notre territoire qui ont besoin de à
ses relations avec les grandes
métropoles
le deuxième c'est lié à l'emploi
beaucoup de personnes qui résident à à
lons le saunier qui travaillent ou qui
se forme sur la métropole de lyon et
c'est nécessaire d'avoir ses relations
pendulaires à travers les terreurs où
les tgv
contacté par téléphone la sncf indique
que des solutions alternatives sont
encore à l'étude
il pourrait s'agir de car en attendant
la mise en place de ter